cette fin de semaine sera marquée par
les journées du patrimoine 12000
monument accessible au public dans toute
la france demain et après demain nous
avons choisi ce soir l'exemple de ces
tisseur de soie à lyon
un atelier classé que nous fait
découvrir gérard dalmaz la colline qui
travaille la croix-rousse fief lyonnais
des tisseurs de sa majesté la soie roger
gavaggio a mis vingt ans à savoir
peindre un carré en dix minutes avec une
simple boule de coton
autodidacte virtuose roger estime
pourtant avoir fait le tour du truc
alors pour la 6ème fois il redevient
apprentis mais pas n'importe quel art
fait car il a choisi pour mettre le
dernier tisseur à bras eux devront
encore pour la haute couture
george matt long 85 ans toujours bonnes
mains bon pied bon oeil
pour manoeuvrer navette et canettes il
ne faut pas regarder en l'air de passer
la même chose la navette va passer au
travers des deux parties alors
évidemment on avait au travers des deux
parties
les deux complices sorte de mètres de
tissus unique chaque jour pour balmain
lapidus christian lacroix ou nina ricci
2000 francs le mètre en prix de revient
les quatre métiers l'ourdissoir le web
sont classés monuments historiques
ils datent du xviiie ou de 1831 la
première révolte ouvrière ou encore de
napoléon iii l'époque faste au fait
roger est ce que c'est difficile de
devenir artiste de la trame et de la
chaîne pour un savoir faire un que
georges et s'est patiemment de
m'inculquer je trouve qu'elle a pas mal
de patience pour ça d'ailleurs mais
c'est du doigt de pied jusqu'au bout des
doigts effectivement tout est une
histoire de senti quand je vais me
mettre à travailler une rythmique qui
s'est plutôt bloch georges avec ses 85
ans va arriver pop pop pop pop lock bon
ça
la décourage un peu moins en fait on
continue quand même parce que c'est très
excitant
il y a deux siècles ils étaient des
milliers à tisser ses merveilles y
compris roger et son ancien georges ils
ne sont plus qu'une douzaine de
professionnels lyonnais de haute qualité
en quelque sorte le dernier carré ne
tient qu'à un fil
et pourtant il faudrait absolument que
ce matériau vivant est encore la vie
devant soi
si c'est terminé